[Música]
en las últimas semanas Europa y Estados
Unidos han estado inmersos en un gran
debate en torno al envío de modernos
tanques de ataque a Ucrania porque la
decisión desata tanta controversia dado
que no es la primera vez que la otan
envía armas o equipos militares a ese
país que está en guerra con Rusia La
primera piedra en el camino aparte de la
falta de consenso es Alemania fabricante
de los tanques leopard 2 esto ha
provocado una enorme presión sobre
Alemania y sobre el gobierno liderado
por olafones veamos
la posición de Alemania sobre el envío
de tanques leopardos a Ucrania enfrenta
una creciente presión no solo de sus
socios europeos sino también de su
propio gobierno el domingo por la noche
los medios preguntaron a la ministra de
asuntos exteriores si Alemania Estaba
dispuesta a permitir que Polonia enviara
sus tanques a Ucrania Por el momento no
se ha planteado la cuestión pero si nos
la plantearan no nos interpondríamos
baebok miembro del partido de Los verdes
en la coalición gobernante ha estado
presionando a favor de una mayor
implicación por parte de Alemania en el
conflicto sin embargo el canciller
olafones sigue mostrándose escéptico
respecto a este tipo de decisiones en
militares sus evasivas a primera hora
del domingo hicieron aún más confusa la
postura de Berlín ya que reiteró que los
socios occidentales deben coordinarse
antes de enviar armas
Ucrania debe saber que no vamos a
abandonarla Seguiremos ayudándoles pero
tenemos un principio y es un principio
que creo que es muy importante trabajar
juntos y consultarnos las cosas
[Música]
el ministro de defensa de Alemania se
apresuró a hacer otro comentario más
cauteloso la decisión depende de muchos
factores y se toma En la cancillería
Alemania se ha visto presionada para
tomar una decisión sobre los tanques el
leopard tras semanas de peticiones del
presidente de lensky Y es que aunque la
medida permitiría una contraofensiva de
las tropas ucranianas Olaf shorts teme
traspasar la línea Roja de Moscú y
provocar una nueva escalada de la guerra
Polonia un país que es vecino de
Alemania y de Ucrania que posee también
unidades de estos tanques leopardos ha
dicho que puede abastecer a las tropas
ucranianas con o sin la aprobación de
Alemania porque Alemania tiene que
aprobarlo pues porque es el país
fabricante de estos tanques y tiene que
dar el aval Para que otro país envíe
unidades a un de unidades de sus
productos bélicos a un tercer país en
donde hay un conflicto abierto o activo
pero en realidad Alemania teme cruzar
esa línea roja con Moscú Esto es lo que
dicen desde el gobierno polaco desde
Varsovia escuchemos
es una cuestión que se repiten las altas
esferas políticas de Europa llegarán los
tanques el leopard de Polonia Ucrania
este lunes el gobierno polaco confirmó
que piensa mandarlos y que buscará otra
vía para hacerlo si no recibe la
aprobación de Berlín
solicitaremos dicho consentimiento pero
este es un tema secundario Incluso si al
final no obtenemos ese consentimiento
como parte de una pequeña coalición
Incluso si los alemanes no están en esa
coalición aún así entregaremos nuestros
tanques junto con otros países a Ucrania
y es que Alemania como fabricante debe
otorgar el permiso de reexportación
hacia Ucrania a los países que poseen
estos tanques pero de momento el
gobierno alemán parece no tener una
postura común mientras el cancillero el
sol se muestra escéptico por una posible
escalada la ministra de exteriores
aseguró que no hay motivo para negar la
operación
Por el momento no se ha planteado la
cuestión pero si nos la plantearan no
nos interpondríamos
desde la Unión Europea algunos países
como lituania aseguraron que no hay
buenos argumentos para negar el envío
algo que no ven igual desde el kremlin
que señaló a todos los países que
suministren armas a Ucrania como
responsables de la guerra
Pero por supuesto todos los países que
están involucrados directa o
indirectamente en el suministro de armas
a Ucrania y en el aumento de sus
capacidades tecnológicas son
responsables de esto
Lo principal es que es el pueblo
ucraniano quien pagará el precio de todo
este falso apoyo
Ucrania lleva meses pidiendo los tanques
el leopard ya que el conflicto sin
grandes avances ha pasado a ser una
guerra de desgaste y los tanques
ayudarían a Ucrania a avanzar posiciones
los expertos creen que ambos bandos
están planeando ofensivas para la
próxima Primavera
la pregunta del millón de euros que
decidirá Alemania qué tanto están
presionando sus socios europeos y los de
la otan entre ellos Estados Unidos para
que envíe o autorice el envío de estos
tanques que tanto beneficiaría esto a
Ucrania a la hora del combate de
mandarlos al terreno será esta una nueva
provocación para Rusia usará Moscú este
episodio como una excusa para escalar el
conflicto y Ser aún más agresiva en el
terreno ya desde el kremlin volvieron a
mencionar esas temidas palabras Arsenal
nuclear Hay muchísimas preguntas por eso
hoy en el debate de France 24 Alemania y
sus tanques que dividen a Europa para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
beata boina ella es internacionalista
profesora de relaciones internacionales
en el Tec Monterrey en su sede en Ciudad
de México fue embajadora de Polonia ante
el gobierno de México y de los países
Centroamericanos entre los años 2014 y
2018 y también con nosotros Hugo Harvey
Valdez él Es doctor en estudios
internacionales también es investigador
de la Universidad de las Américas él se
encuentra en la ciudad de Santiago en
Chile ustedes nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también hacen parte de este
debate dejen todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y también
en instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_eez@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también que todos
los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
le voy entonces la bienvenida a beata
boina en la Ciudad de México villata
como siempre Un gusto tenerla aquí en el
debate de France 24 bienvenida y la
pregunta de Punto de partida para el
debate porque Alemania está dudando
tanto en enviar estos tanques
Muchas gracias por la invitación
Santiago un gusto saludar nuevamente en
tu en tu espacio en este programa Mira
pues la verdad es que el debate sobre
los tanques no es un debate nuevo
regresa nuevamente Eso sí es cierto
después de algunos meses porque
recordemos que A mediados del año pasado
también se estaba discutiendo si enviar
o no enviar tanques a Ucrania y apareció
ese tema de los tanques modernos que en
aquel momento fue descartado y los
países como Polonia este decidieron
enviar a Ucrania los tanques Pues de
producción soviética básicamente 200
tanques también algunos otros países que
poseían ese tipo de equipo de los
tiempos incluso soviéticos el debate
regresa de nuevo efectivamente porque
pues estamos prácticamente un año de la
invasión rusa este no se aún definido el
futuro de esta de esta guerra y hay
perspectivas obviamente como lo han
mencionado en el material que hemos
visto de que en primavera ambas van a
iniciar una una ofensiva Rusia para
afianzar sus posiciones
quizás en algunas otras regiones más que
que ha ocupado parcialmente y Ucrania
para Pues básicamente recuperar esos
territorios ocupados por por Rusia y a
raíz de eso hay una necesidad que ha
mencionado el presidente en varias
ocasiones de lograr conseguir
rápidamente los tanques pues más
modernos de los que ya tiene Ucrania que
son de tecnologías soviética Y haréis
eso precisamente pues Alemania como un
importante productor de los tanques
leopard pues aparece en en línea de
debate hasta ese momento tenemos
declaraciones pues bastante claras de
parte de Alemania de que no va a este
proveer directamente los tanques a
Ucrania y parece que esa posición pues
se va a estar manteniendo durante algún
tiempo Aunque Por otra parte me da la
sensación de que se está flexibilizando
la posición acerca de que los países
terceros que poseen esos tanques
alemanes precisamente Pues los pueden
los pueden reportar a Ucrania eso es la
propuesta que ha hecho Polonia
básicamente y están insistiendo los
países bálticos letonia Estonia lituania
Finlandia también en este en ese tema
vamos a conocer la perspectiva de Hugo
en la ciudad de Santiago en Chile hubo
también Bienvenido al programa Gracias
por estar con nosotros y la pregunta de
punto de inicio y de partida porque
Alemania está dudando tanto Cuál es
Cuáles son esas dudas que hay allí en
Berlín para hacer el envío de estos
tanques
Muy buenas tardes saludos a la profesora
boina también un placer compartir con
ella Este este espacio Bueno yo tiendo a
coincidir bastante con lo que señala la
profesora weyna pero en este caso en el
término de Alemania porque Alemania se
resiste porque Alemania no le interesa
figurar como un país que está entrando
de lleno a la a la guerra todos sabemos
que un tanque no supera de la noche a la
mañana Por lo tanto el ya entregar el
tanque Sería más que el involucramiento
de de la pieza de de blindado sino que
sería incluso cooperar con la parte
logística empezar a cooperar con el
entrenamiento con la preparación y esto
no es de un día para otro por lo tanto
yo creo que está primero una carga
histórica de lo que han vivido los
alemanes durante el siglo XX y por otro
lado la contingencia es decir no ser
parte de el catalizador que haga a Rusia
de ocupar armamento que hasta ahora es
mejor no mencionar
Hugo continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa entonces analizando
un poco la posición de Alemania que
pueden hacer desde Berlín ante estas
críticas que le están haciendo No solo
de la Unión Europea sino también a nivel
mundial de una falta de Liderazgo una
falta de dar un paso adelante
precisamente para prepararse para lo que
pueda ser Rusia en Ucrania en los
próximos meses parte de eso es abastecer
y mantener bien equipado a Ucrania para
que pueda defenderse Esto se lo van a
cobrar al gobierno de Olaf shorts
Sí yo creo que en algún momento se lo
pueden cobrar pero en realidad Por qué
exigirle el liderazgo a Alemania si
Alemania es un integrante más de la de
la otan en este caso Alemania no deja de
Tener razón cuando le exige a Estados
Unidos que entregue tanques seis brams y
otros sistemas de armas de Estados
Unidos también tiene su propia lógica y
señala que en caso entregar tanques
abrams va a ser sumamente difícil la
preparación en distintos tipos de
sistema de sistemas de arma entonces hay
una una situación que tiene varios
varias capas primero la capa de lotan de
poder mantener una una cohesión de la
otan que se ha visto tan fragmentada
vemos que hay países que no no han no se
han manifestado ni en un sentido ni en
otro después está la capa de lo que está
sucediendo entre Estados Unidos y y la
unión sovié perdón y Rusia en este caso
también va a entrar en juego la
efectividad de los tanques decir que un
tanque sea superior a otro en el terreno
y aquí me estoy bajando bastante al
plano táctico puede tener repercusiones
que puedan hacia los otros niveles de la
de la conducción y después ya está el
tema de Ucrania directamente con Rusia y
ahí dice que realmente está el
compromiso de occidente y los países de
la otan de cooperar a la defensa y
podemos ver como el temor en cierta
forma va disminuyendo hacia el oeste es
decir los países que están más cercanos
a Ucrania son los más interesados en que
se detenga El Avance ahora que se prevé
por parte de de Rusia y entre otros
factores ahora que son los
entrenamientos con elemento aéreo que se
están haciendo en Bielorrusia Entonces
está sumamente complicado El el
escenario y uno No sabría decir claro
quién es el responsable o a quién se le
va a cobrar algún tipo de factura más
adelante fíjate Cuál es su perspectiva
Alemania está simplemente como dice Hugo
también haciéndole un llamado a los
otros países como bueno no somos los
responsables no somos los únicos que
tenemos que hacer el suministro de estos
tanques otros países lo pueden hacer
pero tampoco le da la Polonia que por
ejemplo ya alzó la mano y dijo nosotros
estamos en plena disponibilidad para
enviar los tanques cuando sea necesario
los mismos tanques fabricados en
Alemania pero tampoco da la licencia
Mira pues yo creo que el tema de
Alemania es un tema bastante complejo Y
a lo largo de este año y de año y un
poco más del gobierno de sols hemos
visto que la verdad es que el liderazgo
de olapsol sí ha fracasado en diferentes
ámbitos recordemos que es un gobierno de
coalición en el cual como partido
principal tenemos a la socialdemocracia
después de que tradicionalmente ha
tenido muy buenas relaciones con Rusia y
esas buenas relaciones se resienten
mediante la sensación Precisamente en
este año de la guerra con diferentes
tipos de decisiones que básicamente
sirven un poco para frenar un mayor
involucramiento de Alemania contra Rusia
y así podría percibirse efectivamente el
envío de los tanques que ya se trata se
puede decir de tipo de armamento mucho
más defensivo que es mucho más ofensivo
que defensivo en La coalición alemana
tenemos dos partidos más que es el
partido verde que precisamente la
ministra de relaciones exteriores que
tiene declaraciones mucho más atrevidas
cuando habla de la guerra de Rusia
contra Ucrania Pues la verdad es que no
necesariamente encaja o empata al cien
con las declaraciones del canciller
shorts y finalmente el partido liberal
fdp entonces hay esa esas divisiones
dentro de la coalición alemana que hacen
que la posición de todo el gobierno es
una posición muchas veces contradictoria
y débil Por otra parte también hay que
recordar que Alemania es un país que
durante se puede decir muchas décadas ha
sido básicamente ausente en cuanto a la
política de defensa política de
involucramiento en el exterior y ese
cambio ha ido llegando a Alemania con
pues cierta lentitud ciertas
dificultades y este precisamente a raíz
de la de la invasión rusa es esta
intentando realizar un gran cambio en la
política de seguridad de Alemania
también a través de inversiones en la
militarización en la modernización del
equipamiento Y estos meses nos
demuestran que realmente es muy difícil
cumplir con ese propósito que anunció el
canciller el año pasado de gastar en
defensa dos por ciento del pib todo eso
se puede decir influye impacta
efectivamente en pues la posición de
Alemania sobre el envío de los tanques y
hace que realmente desde hace pues
prácticamente un año tenemos una
posición de Alemania contradictoria y
una ausencia de Liderazgo que la verdad
es que sí en Europa se espera que
Alemania tenga liderazgo en varios
ámbitos obviamente dado que es un país
más relevante de la Unión Europea entre
términos políticos en términos
económicos claro es el es el país con
una gran representación en el parlamento
europeo y además pues es el motor
económico de la Unión Europea también
hay que decirlo pero entonces beata
continuó con usted ante esa ausencia de
Liderazgo Y ante esa también ausencia de
algún tipo de postura por otros países
de la otan y de la Unión Europea ahí
surge Polonia ahí puede ser una
oportunidad para el gobierno polaco
tomar un poco más de liderazgo en cuanto
al conflicto Ucrania porque entendemos
obviamente las razones que tiene Polonia
el pasado histórico que tiene con esa
difícil relación con Rusia y con la
entonces Unión soviética y aquí hay
intereses que van respaldados por los
tres estados bálticos que usted también
los mencionaba es la oportunidad para
Polonia de tomar una posición de más
liderar liderazgo en el conflicto y ser
por ejemplo ese país del este que empuje
la posición de la otan dado que Alemania
pues está un poco digamos más lenta para
tomar las decisiones cuando le están
pidiendo que Que decida rápido
Mira yo creo que sí y Polonia durante
esos meses ha demostrado claramente que
quiere ser líder en este en este ámbito
precisamente de ayuda a Ucrania a través
de diferentes se puede decir maneras de
apoyar a este país No solamente en
términos militares también en términos
de acogida de los refugiados ucranianos
en términos de ayuda humanitaria
etcétera etcétera y en ese sentido sí la
voz de Polonia parece que en el ámbito
de la alianza atlántica Sí Cuenta
bastante Polonia propone ciertas
soluciones y es una de las soluciones
precisamente enviar los tanques alemanes
que están en Polonia como país tercero a
Ucrania con la aprobación de Alemania no
habían efectivamente el Primer Ministro
de Polonia
moravídez que en algún momento dijo que
podrían enviarlo incluso sin aprobación
de Alemania no creo que lo hagan la
verdad son formas para presionar
precisamente Alemania para que permita
este este envío ahora bien en la alianza
atlántica obviamente hay muchas
este y muchas posiciones son 30 países
en total este se escuchan voces de
algunos de esos países pero en las
reuniones digamos de Los Embajadores de
los representantes de los países
miembros en el consejo de la alianza
atlántica pues obviamente este se toman
ciertas decisiones al respecto y aquí
pues cuentan opiniones de de todos pero
no cabe duda que Polonia se ha
convertido en la voz de los países que
son vecinos de Ucrania de Rusia y y que
pues directamente están enfrentados con
la situación en el este beata le dijo
sobre la mesa la siguiente pregunta
sobre lo que se está exponiendo Polonia
precisamente por asumir ese liderazgo y
por cruzar de pronto esas líneas rusas
que ha trazado Moscú en cuanto al
conflicto lo dejamos sobre la mesa y
pasa a preguntarle a Hugo sobre la
importancia de este suministro de
tanques para Ucrania hemos visto que la
comunidad internacional básicamente la
otan y países europeos han estado
constantemente enviando ayuda militar La
Unión europe también aprobó 500 millones
de euros adicionales más en ayuda para
Ucrania pero
aquí en qué beneficiaría la guerra el
envío de estos tanques porque la
controversia es como Bueno pero han
enviado otro tipo de equipos militares
Existen los drones para hacer otro tipo
de ataques aún más sofisticados porque
ahora la importancia es en el terreno
tener tanques en el terreno de combate
claro aquí Creo yo que lo importante en
esta fase lo que se viene ahora yo lo
que lo que uno se podría
visualizar digamos que viene una
contraofensiva nuevamente desde
Bielorrusia con blindados Entonces sería
recomendable para Ucrania tener tanques
para poder cortarlo más lejos de lo que
cortaron el ingreso aquí y por otro lado
va a tener que romper las barreras
defensivas que están en el este de
Ucrania en los cuatro obras que que se
anexonó Rusia y ahí vemos que ya se está
haciendo fuerte la defensa rusa entregó
donet pero para hacerse fuerte al este
del del río por lo tanto en esos dos
frente van a ser necesarios se pueden
hacer maniobras cuando empieza la
primavera se puede maniobrar se pueden
utilizar de buena forma estos tanques y
obviamente van a tener que ser
reforzados con armamento antiaéreo que
todavía falta mi punto de vista y con
artillería de largo alcance para poder
ir
en este caso enblandeciendo o tratar de
mitigando digamos la efectividad de las
defensas rusas sin embargo ya vemos que
la táctica o la o la estrategia que está
teniendo Rusia debe afectar los
intereses o las condiciones de bienestar
de la población civil porque se entiende
que la guerra es un fenómeno político y
parte de la base de un apoyo digamos de
la población
Hugo continuó con usted otro actor
importante en este debate y en estas
discrepancias en torno a los tanques
Estados Unidos usted mencionaba al
principio del programa en su primera
intervención que a Estados Unidos
también le ha reclamado porque no ha
enviado parte de sus tanques diciendo
que técnicamente son muy avanzados pero
que sería muy difícil suministrar
repuestos hacer los entrenamientos pero
no ha habido ningún problema a la hora
de mandarlos Afganistán de ofrecerlos
para las tropas devotan en otros tipos
de conflictos en Irán Perdón en Irak en
otros escenarios y ahora sí Estados
Unidos se muestra un poco más reservado
a la hora de ofrecer su equipamiento de
tanques
pero efectivamente aquí centro la
disyuntiva es decir los organismos
internacionales los países más poderosos
son sumamente creativos el momento de
cuando realmente están sus intereses en
juego en este caso yo no sé si Estados
Unidos tendrá tanto interés en juego en
Ucrania Porque creo yo que no habría
tomado una actitud mucho más activa
desde el punto de vista político ahora
desde el punto de vista operacional y
táctico yo tiendo a entender mejor que
es difícil entregar estos tanques no
solamente por lo que simboliza un tanque
sino porque se Sería mucho más diversa
la gama de repuestos de munición de
entrenamiento yo tiendo a creer eso sin
embargo también está como bien señalado
usted la contraparte que en otros
lugares
están más prestos y ya se están
preparando con una mayor cantidad de
tiempo ahora hay que considerar que
desde marzo hay una brigada en Grecia
una brigada norteamericana de la primera
división de caballería que ya se está
preparando es decir en su momento fue
para lograr algún tipo de visualización
en contra de Putin que no tuvo mayores
resultados sin embargo están ahí ese
armamento cosa de que Estados Unidos
Dígale vamos Pero obviamente está
caminando con cierto cuidado para No
tampoco ser el catalizador de una mayor
ofensiva rusa o con otro tipo de
armamento Beta retomó la comunicación
con usted que a qué se está exponiendo
Polonia tomando este liderazgo frente a
Rusia en este conflicto y también la
posición de otro actor importante que ya
lo estaba analizando Hugo y es Estados
Unidos
mira en cuanto a Polonia Pues la verdad
es que desde el comienzo de la guerra de
Rusia contra Ucrania el país y el
gobierno es consciente de que esta
guerra es crucial efectivamente Y
frenarla este es la mejor garantía para
la seguridad de Polonia y y Polonia está
preparándose incluso para un escenario
peor o sea el caso de que esta guerra se
extienda ahora se vea eso poco probable
yo diría más bien se extiende Más allá
del territorio de Ucrania O sea hay
diferentes escenarios que se están
evaluando en ese en ese contexto y vimos
como puede ser la reacción de Polonia en
ese en ese contexto y los riesgos que
que corre este país cuando cayó hace
hace un par de meses un misil de
producción rusa pero resultado de la
defensa antiaérea ucraniana en el
territorio de Polonia ahora bien Si
vemos el papel de otro actor los Estados
Unidos actor crucial desde el punto de
vista de del desarrollo de la guerra
Pues la verdad es que yo creo que hay
que reconocer que los Estados Unidos han
sido y son digamos el apoyo fundamental
han proporcionado más de o sea
prácticamente como cuarenta y ocho mil
millones de dólares de ayuda Ucrania
desde el comienzo de enero hasta
prácticamente finales de noviembre la
Unión Europea en ese mismo tiempo más o
menos proporcionó 51 mil millones de
dólares ahora bien el apoyo que han
proporcionado los estadounidenses ha
sido principalmente el apoyo militar y
en ese sentido Pues sí ha habido
diferentes envíos entregas de armamento
incluidos los los las bacterias de
defensa antimisil Patriot a Ucrania que
son muy relevantes desde el punto de
vista precisamente de la defensa del
cielo de Ucrania aunque también el
entrenamiento para usar ese ese tipo de
este de armamento pues es bastante
complejo los Estados Unidos sí tienen
mucho interés digamos en apoyar a
Ucrania porque no quieren los tanques
pues una de las razones es el aspecto
técnico que ha mencionado ya que se han
mencionado Precisamente en este en este
espacio Pero bueno el aspecto técnico el
aspecto logístico este si están cerca
los tanques que produce Alemania pues
este Por qué digamos
hacer el envío de los tancos desde los
Estados Unidos y por otra parte también
se está hablando del envío de los
tanques desde el Reino Unido que también
hay producción de los tanques británicos
precisamente que podría ser una especie
de solución a raíz de pues ese rechazo
que tiene Alemania para enviar sus
propios tanques a Ucrania pero yo creo
que se va a encontrar finalmente esa
solución de que el país tercero que
tiene tiene tanques
alemanes leopard pueda enviarlos a
Ucrania sí buscaron otro territorio no
alemanes no estadounidenses mandarlos
los británicos quiero que analicemos
ahora en toda esta situación en este
debate el otro lado
de el territorio de combate y es Rusia
Cómo puede estar Rusia capitalizando
esta coyuntura este debate que está
viviendo la Unión Europea la otan y
Estados Unidos y los otros países que
están involucrados en este conflicto
para tomar un poco de partido porque
todas las situaciones en la guerra
tienen que ser aprovechadas de alguna
manera aquí Rusia como estará
aprovechando esta situación y qué cartas
puede tener bajo la mesa para los
próximos meses Hugo adelante
Sí bueno todos los análisis que hacemos
acá son dando impuesto extra racional
pero lamentablemente
Rusia en este en este conflicto y y en
otros conflictos también no toma
decisiones de un punto de vista
racionales es decir aquí operan algunos
algunos fenómenos que se ven en relación
internacionales como el pensamiento
grupal y cómo lo que quiere decir el
líder se lo dice lo que quiere escuchar
el líder se lo dice en sus asesores lo
podemos ver desde las primeras fases del
conflicto por lo tanto es difícil
aventurarse A cuál va a ser la evolución
de las decisiones que va a seguir
tomando tomando Rusia lo que sigue desde
mi punto de vista ha quedado claro es
que la efectividad que el que se
autorrogaba Rusia de su armamento de su
capacidad de planificación de su
capacidad de inteligencia de su
capacidad operacional y En definitiva su
formación de Estado Mayor han quedado en
estrés en estrecho por lo tanto las
cartas que tiene sobre la sobre la mesa
en este caso Rusia Creo yo que es
utilizar diferentes modalidades que
existen de su armamento nuclear si es
que que se puede llegar a utilizar desde
las armas más tácticas hasta las armas
más más poderosas sin embargo Habría que
ver también en qué condiciones
operacionales están Esa esa ojiva
entonces vuelvo a lo que señalé al
principio que es difícil tratar de ver
cómo va a actuar Putin porque las
decisiones pasan por él y podemos ver
que también los cambios que ha realizado
dentro de su de su Estado Mayor de los
de los del nivel operacional de la
conducción tampoco ha tenido los
resultados esperados sobre todo este
último este último cambio con instalar
el general que tampoco hemos visto salvo
más ataques contra la población civil
beata su opinión
Mira pues yo creo que Rusia este seguirá
con la ofensiva o el intento de ofensiva
nueva precisamente y durante todo este
año 2023 vamos a vamos a ver los
intentos de Rusia de consolidar sus
posiciones en las cuatro regiones pero
especialmente en lugares y dones ahora
Bien también hay que reconocer que Rusia
está
perdiendo un poco también los ingresos
económicos los ingresos financieros que
hasta ahora le han permitido mantener
esa guerra hasta la escala como la hemos
visto hasta ahora recordemos que a
partir de diciembre del 2012 de
diciembre del año pasado los países
europeos han dejado de comprar el
petróleo de Rusia o sea fue es el
principal recurso energético que Rusia
vendía el año pasado a los europeos y
del que pues la verdad es que tenía
grandes ingresos para su presupuesto
central federal y también pues han
bajado han disminuido muchísimo las
ventas del gas a los países europeos
entonces a raíz de eso del tiempo Putin
se le está acabando un poco para
realizar realmente Una ofensiva
amplia fuerte y de larga y de larga
duración por eso La verdad es que sí
este Podemos esperar un ataque nuevo
consolidado de Rusia más o menos en
primavera y para para eso también en
Rusia se está haciendo los planes para
ampliar las fuerzas armadas armadas
rusas el tema principal cuando hablamos
de los tanques Y cómo Putin lo puede de
alguna forma
aprovechar es el tiempo y es el punto
sobre el cual los ucranianos ponen
atención porque se necesita tiempo
rapidez especialmente para que las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas pues cuenten
con un equipo un armamento más moderno
Especialmente los tanques que les
permitirían efectivamente realizar una
una controversia mucho más eficaz y
necesitan para aprender esos tanques no
Y ese es el punto crucial Claro porque
estos tanques y los despliegan allí en
terreno hay que entrenar a los soldados
a los militares para poderlos operar
para hacerles el mantenimiento necesario
después de estar en el terreno también
hay que dar un suministro un lote de
repuestos para poderlos mantener en
Operación Y darles la mayor vida útil
posible en el combate No es tan fácil
como llegaron a territorio ucraniano
pisaron el suelo del combate y empezaron
a disparar y ahí están eso toma
muchísimo tiempo también para las tropas
adecuarse a este tipo de equipamientos
Aunque leyendo algunos reviews militares
decían que las tropas ucranianas pues ya
por estar un año en conflicto estaban
tan habituadas a ciertas operaciones de
ciertos equipos europeos y
estadounidenses que les podría ser muy
fácil habituarse a estos nuevos equipos
si llegaran a ser desplegados allí en el
terreno ucraniano en el terreno de
combate sigo analizando la posición de
Rusia Porque además de esta falta de los
recursos económicos y esta baja en sus
ventas internacionales que menciona
beata hay que poner un ingrediente
adicional Y es que Rusia va a elecciones
en el 2024 y el kremlin todavía no ha
dicho si Putin será o no candidato de
aspirar a la reelección para un cuarto
mandato como presidente de la federación
porque lo traigo a la mesa de debate
porque esto claramente va a tener
presión sobre el gobierno sobre los
resultados que tienen que tener en la
guerra y esto me lleva a preguntarles
entonces la falta de recursos esta
necesidad de empezar a mostrar triunfos
en ese conflicto de Cara a esas
elecciones no llevará a Rusia a medidas
desesperadas a tomar decisiones
militares desesperadas y extremas con
tal de Mostrar buenos resultados y que
está ganando la guerra porque como han
dicho ellos una potencia del Calibre de
Rusia no se puede dar el lujo de perder
en una guerra como en Ucrania los podría
llevar a medidas desesperadas como lo ve
usted Hugo
Sí bueno que como le dije anteriormente
difícil tratar de de saber qué pasa por
la cabeza por la cabeza de Putin hemos
visto como su asesores le van diciendo
lo que él quiere decir como los
ejercicios sus generales leen papeles o
sea de un discurso aprendido por lo
tanto es difícil eso verlo en términos
en términos políticos sin embargo sí
está en una encrucijada Putin Por qué no
está mostrando éxito en terreno no está
mostrando los éxitos que había señalado
aquí se está dando
el tema de manifiesto
la mala planificación que se realizó la
mal trabajo de inteligencia ya
estratégica y más arriba y por lo tanto
está en una encrucijada porque los
sectores más más duros de
de Rusia ya están presionando para que
en cierta forma haya algún tipo de
modificación en la edad en la política
beta y su opinión
Mira este yo creo que Putin Sí podría
Bueno yo creo que sí está desesperado no
cabe ninguna duda porque una guerra que
iba a durar una semana este ya va a
llegar casi a un año sin perspectivas
por el momento de
de un desenlace favorable victorioso
exitoso para para pero cuando hablamos
de esa desesperación pues pensamos sobre
todo en la posibilidad del uso de armas
nucleares La amenaza de uso de armas
nucleares que ha aparecido a lo largo de
este año en varias ocasiones me da la
sensación me da la sensación de que nos
estamos más bien alejando de escenario
Por qué básicamente por los aliados de
Rusia que son China y es la la India que
han estado Pues un poco más cerca de
Rusia sin ninguna duda de lo que
esperaría el occidente y los mensajes
que ha transmitido el año pasado a
finales del año pasado el presidente de
China al presidente Putin en los cuales
ha destacado con claridad que no se
puede jugar con el tema nuclear y yo
creo que eso es la línea roja que está
frenando a Putin
frenando frente a las decisiones pues
totalmente irracionales me quedan un par
de minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero hacer las conclusiones
les doy suficiente tiempo para que
puedan hacerlas
comienzo entonces con Hugo lo que
podemos ver en los próximos días en
torno a este debate de el uso de estos
tanques alemanes lo que pueda venir del
lado de Rusia también la posición de
Estados Unidos como siempre lo digo no
tenemos la bola de cristal para saber el
futuro y lo que va a pasar pero qué
análisis de perspectiva hacia el futuro
se puede hacer para los próximos semanas
bueno considerando que el tiempo
atmosférico es uno de los condicionantes
en en la guerra yo yo lo que tiendo A
ver es que va a haber una una nueva
ofensiva Rusia desde Bielorrusia Con un
fuerte empleo del elemento aéreo que ha
sido casi ausente en este en esta guerra
y también Yo creo que esa ofensiva la va
a intentar de tener Ucrania para que no
obtenga el objetivo político que es
descabezar a quién y también se van a
requerir romper las defensas como hemos
señalado en endones y Lucas son donde
están más fuertes y para eso necesita el
elemento blindado pero también un
complemento con otro tipo de armamento
que el elemento antiaéreo y todo esto
Tal como decía la próxima vaina también
se le requiere tiempo requiere
preparación porque esto no es de la
noche a la mañana llegar e insertar un
tipo de armamento nuevo en el terreno un
ata su conclusión para el cierre del
programa
estamos en invierno profundo en Europa
no ha sido tan frío como sea
quizás esperado afortunadamente
ha habido muchas luchas en el frente
entre Ucrania y Rusia a pesar de este
invierno Pero la verdad es que las dos
partes están preparando para que
finalice el invierno empiece la
primavera y realmente puedan se pueden
decir hacer dar el último empujón en
esta en esta guerra para Rusia es
crucial obviamente este en este contexto
lograr afianzarse en los territorios que
tiene controlados y Ucrania no cederá y
seguirá con la con la ofensiva para
recuperar esos territorios Por otra
parte la perspectiva de negociación que
siempre Esperamos que va a haber
negociación es muy lejana y hasta yo y
hasta hasta Pues los altas autoridades
como secretario general de las Naciones
Unidas ha mencionado recientemente que
el 9 probabilidades de una mediación
entre las partes en ese momento pues
Hugo les agradezco muchísimo por este
análisis para la audiencia de France 24
gracias por haber estado con nosotros En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos también a ustedes la
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera sigan dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales Gracias por estar con nosotros
[Música]